i saw that it was based on a william
joyce novel bill and i became fast
friends we've met in the mid 90s and and
uh we're at the same exact we're the
same age we grew up loving the same
stuff we just hit off like that and so
early on we decided we got to make a
movie together one way or another be fun
we met for dinner and um
he'd been visiting the frick um
museum and they'd had a they'd had an
exhibition of victorian fairy paintings
up
and
he showed me the catalog
i didn't get to see the the exhibit but
the catalog was enough i was looking at
this thing and and they're just these
incredibly articulate paintings you know
100 years old
of little civilizations in the forest
little you know
magical little people running around but
then also like descriptions of
civilizations and you know
ceremonies and coronations and weddings
and
funerals for animals and i just thought
wow that's that's it that's cool that
that's that's that's where we there's
that's where we should go and bill had a
couple years before done his book
the leaf man and um
you know the story that we cooked up was
one that included the leafmen but
his book is a charming children's book
like a bedtime story really beautifully
rendered with bill's
painting
um but but neither one of us was
interested in that story it was just the
belief that could be cool and then so we
just amped them up into
like warrior samurai warrior and put
them on hummingbirds like little jet
fighters and that was the idea would be
an action movie that's what i wanted to
do because
it's a little unfortunate that animation
starts
in our culture with kids
i've got nothing against kids i've been
a kid
i've raised kids
but i love animation i've loved it all
my life and so it's always you know if
you're going to do animation it's got to
be marketed to kids it's got to be
really kid-friendly and if you're going
to
then they're only a couple of ways you
cross over to the other audience and
that's with comedy usually so we pack
all sorts of comedy in and i wanted to
do it with action and and and advance
and adventure and fantasy i just wanted
to get you to a world where you could
you could only do
an animation so so one thing about it is
i didn't want this you know i said we
started with victorian fairy paintings
but i didn't want anything to be cute
about this i didn't want any cutesy
anything so
you know we decided the leaf men
you know we look we had drawings of the
leaf men with little thatched things
that you can make leaves out of and pull
a belt around them and they look very
cute but i decided um now they should be
cool they should be able to forge metal
they should be able to weave stuff it's
just they're they're smaller than us who
cares so
cool we got that set we used samurai
stuff as reference for that so i guess
this technology is obviously uh affected
it's probably enhanced your
would you say the 3d technology has
enhanced your storytelling you know it
adds i hate to put it this way but it
adds another dimension
you guys can use that one i don't care
you know just
uh
no but it's another element in the
cameraman's two toolkit and the
director's toolkit because you um
i mean
all the stuff we know about composition
size and
you know contrast and color and
um
scale relationships
you just have an extra
element connection so i mean you know
we're always with the camera pushing the
audience's head in and out of the movie
and now you can literally do it you can
literally pull the proscenium past their
ears and back in so
it's really fun to work with and we had
a trem you have a tremendous amount of
control in animation
so how did you approach the cast i mean
you have beyonce you have pitbull you
have colin farrell
um all singers you've all seen yeah
you're not balancing a singer
well it's interesting because you go
character by character
and you just try to pin stuff down and
you know you don't know what your
ensemble is going to be until you're
finished but people say yes right away
for some do
some are very enthusiastic some scratch
their heads some turn you down
but i mean there's a casting director
we've been using at fox for as long as
blue sky's been doing this and he's
really usually pretty good at knowing
who's a rising star and who's going to
be great in a role and who's going to be
hot when the film hits because after all
we could just make this spend four years
making this movie and sit and watch it
ourselves but we would really like other
people other people to see it as well
right right right so i guess that
process of creating an animated film is
what four years
three to three years you need all of
three years and if you're lucky you get
a little more than that so i was in
production for about three and a half
wow
wow and then you cut in music and danny
how did danny alfman come come oh i do
we just went and i just thought of who i
wanted i just wanted really i wanted
like adventures of robin hood i wanted
eric corngold or you know franz waxman
just old school i wanted i wanted to
just like if i wanted to hear
music sync up with somebody getting
punched in the face
you know i wanted that i just i wanted
to be fun and colorful